[Music]
welcome to ear biscuits I'm Rhett and
I'm link this week at the roundtable of
dim lighting we have us hey the two of
us and you hope you're not disappointed
I picture you in some sort of seat
listening to this I think it could be a
it could be a moving vehicle seat
jogging I mean sitting there you could
be jogging I'd but I don't picture you
jogging maybe on a skateboard not that
you don't nuts you're not in shape is
somebody's joints someone is on
rollerblades right now think about that
like oh gosh he's on rollerblades they
look cool they look really cool everyone
when they go by everybody's thinking
that guy must be to listen in the ear
yeah that's an ear biscuits man see he's
got he's got those big headphones on and
the rollerblades that only means one
thing your biscuits okay that's
happening well here's what's gonna
happen on this year biscuit as you know
if you've been listening for any time we
started doing this thing on a
semi-regular basis where we just talked
to one another and it's been fun we've
learned some things about one another
we've taken questions from you
the ear biscuits listeners and asked
them to one another we're gonna continue
in that tradition tonight and we're
gonna talk about is the creative process
as it specifically relates to our music
because songs yeah yeah and not because
but one of the things that's gonna
happen to illustrate this is we're going
to play a lot of music tonight and that
includes a lot of tracks slash demos
slash maybe even not quite demos that
have never seen the light of day that I
don't think anyone other than just the
two of us has ever heard never hit any
one's ears
I mean there's some things that I found
on my phone that you and you had never
heard right voice memo so I mean alright
we're going into voice memo
demo level tonight not to not because we
think we're like the The Beatles or
something and we're open up the archives
and you're gonna be blown away but
because it's kind of ridiculous Anna and
hopefully
in in informative to those of you who
are you know trying to yeah there's
nothing creative out if you're an
aspiring songwriter then maybe this give
you confidence that you can certainly do
better than we can and if you're just a
rollerblader I mean hopefully this is
just be entertaining yeah I think it you
don't even have to like music to get a
kick out of some of the things that we
have tried so we have some questions
that we've gotten off Twitter that we're
going we're gonna go through but first I
think a good place to start
Rhett is with the first comedy song that
we wrote together now I mean we were in
a band together in high school the wax
paper dogs vote and it was comical but
it was not intentionally comical there
were comedy songs written right so the
first intentionally comedic song we
wrote I guess it was 2001 I mean this
was our third roommate in college Greg
it was 2003 jeez it was 2000 it was the
year 2000 because yeah you got married
you got married in 2000 right no and
then Greg and December 2000 so we
decided to write a funny song making fun
of Greg in at his rehearsal dinner we
were going to perform it live at his
rehearsal dinner in order to embarrass
him in front of not only his family but
his fiancee Jenn's family right so we
wrote a song which I I somehow have like
the demo recording of us practicing the
song yeah before we performed it and I
guess we should go ahead and tell him
that this song was then adapted well
here's what we realized we realized a
song about a guy who you lived with for
three years and making fun of him before
he gets married is not something that
has a wide audience there's not a lot of
broad appeal so we decided to change the
words and keep the tune and the guitar
part and that became the unibrow song
right which I'll play a little bit of
that right now
in this awkward position my two eyebrows
have formed a coalition
[Music]
so the universe song actually ended up
being one of our first music videos on
our YouTube channel that went big it was
featured on the homepage of YouTube
that's right back in the day and you can
still watch that music video which
features rets father as one of the guys
in the barber chair that we shave his is
unibrow yeah the good-looking one so so
to go back to this rehearsal dinner with
Greg we wrote this song and the bridge
was well I'll just play it and see if
you can you can hear what we said
[Music]
they know that you were meant for each
other
the best of friends soon to be the best
of lovers we know that you were meant to
be together two peas in a pod two
okay so that's a little embarrassing I
gotta say a couple of things a note is
we sounded like absolute rednecks we
were yeah still still are rednecks just
kind of reformed a little bit we could
not sing well at all I think a dog
actually barked as a result of one of
your harmonies
yeah but the interesting thing we've
seen Greg naked soon you will too hope
you enjoy it more than we do but it was
a hit I think the thing I would like to
stress at the rehearsal day as as it's
not a nationwide you know as bad as that
sounds as embarrassing it as the played
for you it was an absolute hit at the
rehearsal dinner so much so that one of
the most formative conversations that we
have had about our careers took place
right after that you remember this yes
sitting in the car with our water with
our wives with my fiance at the time
your wife of six months and I was gonna
get married to my wife in six months and
they it went over so well they said you
guys need to do something with this like
you can't just get up there and sing
this song and have everybody respond
like that and just move on to the next
thing you've got to keep doing this
you've got to pursue this and I think
that was the beginning of his thinking
in first of all I'm so thankful they
said that because based on that
recording no one should have ever
thought there was any promise there was
any reason to keep pursuing it yeah I'm
very thankful for our wives for seeing
the potential they were like our Simon
Cowell but I mean in fairness the live
performance was much more dynamic and
much more practiced the whole reason of
recording that was so that we could not
forget it but when we started to be like
that that was a turn right as we were
writing it can give us the benefit of
the doubt so we started writing
intentionally funny songs after that and
I mean it wasn't like immediate success
I whether we're oat the unibrow song
pretty much right after that but we also
wrote fartin girl which I don't know why
I'm playing some of this but just
because it's so embarrassing okay
ended up and this is there's a lot
voices in this one this was many of our
friends joined in many who could sing
and many who could not sing as you'll be
able to tell it and as you hear the
chorus of voices
[Music]
Xena
[Music]
[Music]
if she first mustered she might have to
go every
[Music]
Oh
[Applause]
okay so that ladies and gentlemen was
fartin girl an international hit from
rhettandlink now that actually went on
an album that was sold at some point
just mail us the Grammy and I don't
believe that is a trunk that is
available to be bought anywhere thank
goodness no but one of the things that
was very much a part of the process at
that point in our comedy and especially
in our music was as soon as we wrote it
as soon as we came up with it a line we
wrote it and moved on and there was
never an evaluation of hold on what did
what just happened what did we just
write did we just really write a song
that says Tina gets the laughs when she
farts in a group have you ever been in a
party where a girl named Tina farted and
gets the laughs that gets the laugh it
was all a setup that's another thing it
was all a setup for poop which is
because some group rhyme same link yeah
so as soon as we figured out oh listen
it'll be great if we can just say if she
farts too much she'll poop so hey let's
just start it with something about group
Oh Tina gets the last thing is we just
established that we are married men at
this point we're third grade and we put
it on an album I mean my my art 8 and 9
year old sons wouldn't had more decency
now did not write as don't even know
about this so my kids would be singing
this song left and right all throughout
the house if I were to play this for him
but it because I the reason we wanted to
play that is not just because we thought
you'd laugh and how horrible it was was
because the process I will give us some
credit over the past 14 years
the process has changed significantly
and I think for me one of the the things
that I've noticed is that it's so much
more iterative than it used to be
because where it was Oh poop rhymes with
group boom let's sit down let's record
this invite some friends over let's
record this with them it's so much more
iterative when it starts with it with us
an idea and that idea and whether it's
the the chorus or whether it's the
melody or whether it's the muse
itself takes a lot of different forms
before it takes its final form well okay
so I've got a Twitter question here and
I think we can get into that
junus puh puh puh puh that's what yeah
yes when we start a project do we
already clearly know what the finished
product will be like or does the idea
evolve
I think he may be talking about like a
concept for like for a particular song
but I think what you're saying is that
this song does evolve as you go on a
perfect example I think we can walk
through it's my belly button one of our
most recent songs just to kind of take
it to the other extreme
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
that's what the bellybutton song or it's
my bellybutton became but the song
started in a much different place than
that we actually have the first the demo
version that we did right when we came
up with this idea we sat down we wrote
some music for it and then link recorded
a melody of some of the lyrics that hip
we had written see if this is in any way
similar to the final version
[Music]
in the same place and recovered in we go
to the memory of what was that I mean I
think you had I was working on something
else and you sat down at like the
computer and the keyboard and kind of
developed that backing track which was
just playing in the room and then I took
it and tried to come up with some sort
of melody and and we had talked about
the concept there saying a few of the
lyrics right but the thing that we had
talked about was we want to do a song
about grown men who discovered their
belly buttons they think that they maybe
they've been shot and they both healed
in the same spot and they've got a scar
in the same spot what are the chances Oh
highly improbable that's highly
improbable and we and we wanted that to
be what the song was
mm-hmm then months later because that
we're in a very weird sounding oh yeah
yeah that was in 2013 actually that was
an October of last year that we
conceptualized that lots of time past
and then we revisited it this year and I
remember saying you know what I want to
take a day and I and I'm gonna you were
working on something I was like I'm
gonna take a day and I want to revisit
this bellybutton song and see if I can
move it along and I sat down and
listened to exactly what we just
listened to and I was like oh this is
horrible we can't we can't do this
right it it's funny because I pulled it
up in order to email it to you so that
you'd have it and when I pulled it up
and listened to it I was like this is
horrible we can't do this but I sent it
to you anyway and I was like this is his
problem today well and then you came
back and said I didn't use that and it's
not okay well but the thing is is that I
listened to it and I was like you know
what we should handle this whole
discovery of the bellybutton in the
conjecture as to what it might be let's
handle that in a sketch at the beginning
of this thing and then let's just let
the song be about celebrating the
bellybutton right like post realization
and so then I updated it with this
version which is a little bit more like
the final version but still a little
different
extra you added a baby you were really
reaching I was singing it to a woman it
was you were yeah I mean it was very
emotional it was very dramatic
subversion should be overdramatic like
these guys they discovered their belly
button and then they seen this really
dramatic song but then you know I never
played that for you I I cuz I played
that this is like the first time I'm
hearing it yeah right so I'm like oh oh
gosh maybe we should do that one too and
so I never played you that version
because I listened back to that and I
knew that that wasn't good enough and in
another couple of weeks past and then
when I revisited it again I said this
needs to be this has got to be happier
more ridiculous this should be a pop
song and then that ended up you can see
that the course was almost there right
right lots of things change they're
gonna be in the belly belly button
really really something it became to the
hook really but it's just it it that's
how the song got to the sound that it
ended up having but let's talk about how
they can the concept change did you have
another version though didn't you I
thought you have one more demo to play I
would I do I have that I have basically
what is the very last version before we
change the concept
I can't believe we've lived to be this
oh and somehow we have never seen this
hole I can't believe we've lived to be
this oh and somehow we have never seen
this hole okay so that that you you it
was kind of repetitive at this point
that demo that was just okay it's gonna
have more of a pop beat it's gonna have
little beat up beating more poppy that
piano and that kind of thing and so then
that at that point is when I brought it
back to you right and when we were in
our office and I was like okay here's
the updated version I think we're onto
something here in terms of the sound and
you have a chorus to because that was
the best part
yes yeah that was you also had that
right the course the course was there
and then we kind of just added some
jokes in and you know added the rap and
all of that and started to structure it
but we but we had to figure out where
the song was going to go I think that
that's always the second question the
first question is what's this song about
what's the comedic angle to guys
discover the bellybutton but then it has
to go somewhere because I don't think
that concept is enough to support a song
and we decided we didn't have the trees
yet right well we had telescopes going
into the belly button well that's the
thing that we said was this song has got
to go crazier right it's got to go more
into left field and so the first time I
do idea we came up with well let's get
to the point where these guys start
selling basically a charger look at in
their belly buttons with it with
telescopes and somehow I don't know I
can't remember exactly what that what we
this how we came up with this but it was
we were also going to give away
magazines about horse Mane's horse mane
horse mane magazine it was a miniature
miniature horse mane mangas it was crazy
it was youth you got if you came and
looked at the belly button you got a
free subscription to a horse miniature
horse mane magazine and then we said
okay but before we get to
crazytown with miniature horseman
magazine let's try some things like we
didn't have the Nugget yet because I
made that up later but we had a couple
of the other things including trees be
dazzling it and and putting a seat in
there and a tree growing out of the
belly button
but then when we revisit it we said hold
on let's let's keep if we keep running
with the trees it could actually be
logical we don't have to go to a horse
mane magazines which doesn't make any
sense so we can carbon offset ourselves
and then the song kind of it just went
from there but you so you can see what
we're saying this is kind of the
iterative process of writing a song I
mean since last October yeah and so it
it's been it gets to the point where it
becomes it's not just a song about
bellybuttons it's a song about somehow
about it's almost an Earth Day and an
Earth Day song kind of an anti Earth Day
song almost in an ironic way but it took
five steps to get to that point right a
couple of other questions sort of Sam
asked is one of you more of an idea
centered person whereas the other acts
as a filter for the ideas well I think
that I think that this bellybutton song
is the perfect example of how we work a
lot of times yeah and that is right and
we may I don't know if we've ever talked
about this specifically first of all
both of us come up with all kinds of
ideas and both of us help finish and
filter lots of ideas our process is
incredibly collaborative and I'm not
just making this up I it is truly the
case that a lot of the time we do not
remember who came up with the idea when
we think back on a specific idea it's
like I think maybe you've said something
in a conversation and then I immediately
had another idea that built on it and
then we're off to the races and we and
we build ideas that's how we always work
but I do think that I'm more forward
thinking than you and you're more
detail-oriented than I am we established
that when we talked about our
personality differences on an episode of
good mythical morning and what that
lends itself to a lot of times is is
I'll come up with 15 different ideas for
songs you'll help establish what the
best idea is and then if
we move forward with an idea and I kind
of get it off the ground like this
bellybutton song I probably would have
just been fine finishing the song making
it sort of an ode to bellybuttons but we
were sitting there in your light we got
to take it it's got to go somewhere else
it's got to go to a new level and that's
when the whole left-field conversation
started happening and it became the song
about bellybutton trees and carbon
offsets I think that it's I think that's
the answer the question is that a lot of
times there's this I might have an idea
but it never it never becomes what it's
going to be until you marinate on it and
turn it into what it is because that's
how our brains work as a default but sir
but certainly it works the other way as
well yeah I have ideas and you make them
better
Smith Brent 518 tweeted who makes the
witty comebacks or do you create your
own parts like an epic rap battle nerd
geek or manliness or just the original
epic rap battle I guess what he's asking
is do we each separately write our own
parts of the rap battle and then legit
so we're legitimately rap battling and
the answer is no I hate to crush your
your hopes I don't know that's ever
happened rent 518 yeah I mean what it's
still just very collaborative III think
until the very last when we're divided
and up we kind of divorce the lyrics and
the whole writing of us of the rap from
who's gonna be delivering it because I
wouldn't be fair and it doesn't matter
at least at that point I mean there's a
once the song is written we then we have
to determine who's gonna say what but
it's as we're writing the lines we don't
know who's saying what or how we're
gonna divide it up we're just trying to
make the best song ever and write it
because we both win if it's a great song
right and and I'd say that you are
you're more of a student of rap than I
am you listen to more rap and so
typically what we do and I think this
has become and it's also a detail or
anything for me to kind of take write to
craft a rap but so is something like the
text Burt I'm at expert rap I'm one of
our most recent reps what I'll do is
I'll sit down and I'll just write a lot
of concepts like this would be funny or
be just there
there was a joke about texting with your
feet it would be funny if there was a
joke about a masseuse a Swedish masseuse
giving you thumb shiatsu and I could
have a yogi but I don't think about the
rhyme scheme I don't think about the
flow just come up with these different
ideas and then kind of you take it all I
move on to something else yeah we're
always working on something I'll move on
to something else and you'll kind of sit
there in the office and kind of toy with
the lyrics until you kind of landed
something then bring it back to me as a
demo and then I'll kind of you say well
I think I'd rather say it like this or
maybe it would be funny if we did it
like this or it would be a better foot
and then way the final version is a
collaborative again so the typical
process is and I think this is probably
typical of lots of people who work
together which I would say that one
lesson learned or I don't need I don't
even know what it would be like to to
create things apart from you
apart from link we is such a
collaborative process of handing things
back and forth like two guys working on
the same project and kind of all right
you take this for a while I'm gonna go
work on something else give it back to
me when you've moved it along I would
say that's an encouragement to if you're
having trouble creatively you come to
creative roadblocks find somebody to
work with because I think so many of the
creative breakthroughs that we've had
have been related to the fact that we
hand things back and forth until it
becomes what it's going to become and
only recently I think in the past year
have we determined that we should spend
more time on writing jokes and coming up
with funny concepts and we're at the
beginning middle and end of a song
before we start crafting the song itself
especially for a wrap I mean it's
there's somewhat many more jokes crammed
into a rap we learn to write as many
jokes as we could and then you kind of
have things to choose from to kind of
make your rhymes in the second half
whereas before we would just start at
the beginning to start writing and
rhyming as we went and you would end up
with filler and things that didn't work
well related question to that says Ellie
brash ex asks do you write lyrics first
or compose the music first by the way
love you guys you are going to
say that I mean but it's in the tweet
heart to actual icon hearts there for me
I think hearts for me that I don't get a
hard-on well I think one of them for me
says you guys you know I'm gonna take
one of those hearts I don't even know
this girl Megan I'll take any hearts I
take you can have all the hearts mind a
wife what they were both for me anyway
I've got I think when it's a wrap like
like link was saying a lot of times it's
very much jokes even lyrics first and
then I can't write the lyrics without
music I actually tried that because I
tried I thought it I tried to change the
music on text but halfway through and I
was like what can't I can't change the
tempo it's not working yeah so well so
usually we do have the beat that we've
gotten someone to make for us that's
another thing with with raps we a lot of
times we have a producer create
something and then we kind of help guide
that process with our songs we always
write the the music for those so we're
not you know we're writing the the music
for that for the songs and then trying
to come up with the melody / lyrics and
a really funny example something that we
found when we were going through all
these old
yes demo levels this was on my phone
yeah it was another voice memo when we
were working on the my hair song which I
remember how that one worked
I don't remember whose idea was but I
know that you came up with a hook like
the the piano hook for the way that goes
I think it goes from the verse in
through the chorus
my hair goes up my hair goes down the
beginning of the idea yeah was I was
like I got an idea about a song for hair
going up in here going down because my
hair goes up your goes down all I got is
this and it was just the chorus and then
we played a little bit away well but the
the the the verse could be something
like this but I have no idea what the
lyrics are gonna be I have no idea what
the melody should be but we had this
little we had a beat and we had a chord
progression and then and that was all we
had and you had that on on your computer
yeah and then you started working on the
second caption fail and I said alright
I'm gonna work on this melody and then I
kind of had something I kind of worked
on a melody and recorded as I went so I
wouldn't forget it because what you
learn when you're writing the songs is
you get something great and you know
like I'm never gonna forget that you go
to lunch and you come back and you do
not remember it so that's why we have so
many voice memos on our phone was
because we forgot things that we thought
were genius actually you're just
documenting proof that what you came
with really was a genius as you'll see
so this is the my hair goes verse melody
I was just making up words off the top
of my head and trying to come up with
the melody something that was catchy
check one two testing testing this is my
hair goes up and if I wrote the song and
you sing it with me would to people
their bedroom and if we went down like
this and up like this and middle fall
around the world then everybody would be
singing the song and passing it on the
girls yeah I'm trying to remember this
way to sing so I can sing it with these
new words and when I add in two words
and you sing along it'll be like two
floating turns and if floating turds are
cool and we are cool then we can float
along with them and you can vote for
different weirdo roofers in the room
oh my goodness Rufus it's like if Bill
Cosby were like that got his wisdom
teeth out like what that was the funny
thing about it is is the melody that you
came up with
there was actually better than the
melody we landed on you were like it was
a very our Kelly thing you kind of fact
we backed off on the art Kelly nature
that because it was almost too
over-the-top and we also didn't include
lyrics about turds
if the turds are cool oh gosh that's
embarrassing
well I know that that existed again I
I'm hoping first of all you if you know
us you know that we result a resort to
bathroom humor it's a natural that was a
perfect example of it just it's in your
brain now conscious the turds are gonna
come out that brain turds are you gonna
come out you can't help it but I'm
hoping that you know something about
girls I said something about girls the
girls are share it share it with the
people we'll share it with girls
thank you sir which doesn't mean that's
great we want people to share our music
with girls yeah guys but I do hope that
you know I remember when we were first
getting started I mean I started playing
the guitar when I was 17 in the band we
had already started we're because we
were two lead singers and then I was
like when one of us needs to play an
instrument and in it that what Patricia
Joyce 94 ask you how long did it take
you to learn to play guitar what was
your favorite song to play I don't know
what my favorite song to play was but I
do know that I learned in a matter of
weeks I remember I got the guitar you
learned you bought you bought a fake
book that's what their car right where
they tell you how to play guitar that's
got a fake book I don't know why but I
think that's where it's just you mean
where it just has forward just got the
fakes in it yeah
and you got the Eagles one and you got
Lynyrd Skynyrd yeah and it was kind of
the the egos one was great because the
Eagles have so many just chords that
makes pastrami yeah but the Lynyrd
Skynyrd was just I had I had all these
electric guitar riffs for like
give me back my bullet yeah that kind of
thing the point I am making though is
that I think about that process of
trying to learn how to write songs and
we kind of felt our way through it and
we didn't have a whole lot of people
telling us what to do but these little
tips like you know if you come up with a
melody sing it immediately so you won't
forget it if you don't have what the
song is gonna be about go ahead and
record yourself singing about turds or
whatever because you're going to help
establish what the song is going to
become obviously we didn't write a song
about turds not that we're above it we
started this thing off talking about the
girl that farts in a group and then ends
up pooping so we're not above it but I
think for anybody out there who is
aspiring to be a songwriter those are
some tips that we that we would throw
your way is that just get something out
there open it up don't wait until you've
got it completely formulated in your
mind adain 0 9 ask us how do you come up
with the premise or concept for your
songs I you know I think we've got the
three or four different ways that we
come up with the concept I mean
something I as we've already established
obviously just an idea will pop in our
brains I don't know how you came up with
the idea of writing his song about two
guys discovering their belly buttons
what what 30 it was a sketch I thought
it would be a funny sketch but how did
okay but how did you come up with the
idea for that period no idea you like
you're like looking at your belly button
I think I think I may have seen
something about I know what it was I saw
something on television about
self-awareness and how at a certain age
babies realize that their bodies are
like they they have some sort of sort of
them part of them right like what if
what if the grown men realize that oh
they might find their belly button right
you know Jim then it just from there
okay yeah I remember coming up with a
I'm a thoughtful guy I mean I was I was
driving into the Fatburger parking lot I
was gonna get me a fat burger and there
was an ad on the radio it was a dating
ad on the radio and it's
something about I'm a thoughtful you
know if you want to meet a thoughtful
guy and I was like well I'm a thoughtful
guy but I'm like well I don't need a
date but that's kind of funny could also
just mean it I think you think about and
then I just jotted that down and then
two weeks later I was I was looking
through a list when we were talking my
song ideas and it came up but I mean
yeah I don't know I'm not gonna say it's
a sad fact a lot of the ways we come up
with our songs adain oh nine is through
sponsorship I mean all of our rap
battles was started with a sponsor
dentine wanted to they wanted to do
something that it that tied gummed
together with confidence confidence to
start a relationship and that led to
epic rap battle and then when we put we
put epic rap battle manliness to a
sponsor and then same thing with Tiger
Direct and nerve versus geek right so a
lot of it has to do with somebody just
saying we want something that speaks to
a certain thing approach that kind of
like a math problem and I don't want to
talk about too much because it's really
boring well I think it's nice to have a
constraint or two we allotted we were
reactive sometimes and I think that's a
good thing as having something having
somebody request that you write
something for them can help you come up
with ideas that you would not have come
up with if it was just you writing along
listening to the radio and hearing a
commercial about a dating website well I
mean that's why why we came up with the
five word song title idea I mean the any
machines guys are friends they came up
with the idea for films and they gave us
permission to use it for songs too but
and really when we first started making
YouTube videos we were already doing
that not five word song titles but just
submit a song title the fear of frog
song one of the first songs on our
channel after unibrow and that's part of
the West sea boom right no it was after
that but it was a submit a song idea
within our some you know fanbase someone
submitted that idea
and then when we came back with the the
idea to do five word song titles we made
a video we said hey we're gonna we want
to write a song based on your
suggestions the first one that we wrote
was nil away for top hat time we saw
that we said okay surely there's a song
in Nilla wafer top hat time wrote a very
quick and easy song and did a live
performance of it for our music video
but then a number of months passed and
it surprisingly we asked people to
submit five word song ideas and there
might be i remember going through and
looking at the suggestions for those
five word songs looking at like a
thousand in one sitting
oh yeah and not being able to find one
that i thought we can make into a good
song
i don't know what it was was just like
man i thought that there would be so
many of these that would work but so
many of the people's suggestions were
things like purple dinosaur kitten
doughnut hole or something like that you
know what i mean like it's it's not
really a concept there and then all of a
sudden I wish I knew who suggested this
it's in you know we gave him the credit
in the video yeah it's there
we saw rub some bacon on it it's like
that is funny and that's that's actually
Serge underscore beetee's question was
how did you come up with the rub some
bacon on it idea well mmm it was a
suggestion that was one of the five word
songs now you have a demo of that we had
a really hard time right and we rub some
bacon on it I definitely remember that
is it too soaps you got two things about
that first thing is we wrote the chorus
for rub some bacon on it at least four
times so that Beach Boys style rub some
bacon on it that was after we had
visited many different courses that we
didn't like over over several weeks then
we finally land on that chorus and then
we've got this rub some bacon on it
chorus additional line in the course
that we wanted and this is originally
what it sounded like just me singing it
as a demo
well some make in on it
Russell Megaton it making on it now I
remember as we were writing that and
recording that listening to the back of
a mountain we just sound like dumb as
dirt like knuckleheads singing like
either that or like some type of frat
guy that you don't want to hang out with
and really I don't know what to do we
couldn't come up with anything better
and then it was the idea was what if a
robot synced what if it was a robot
voice and we kind of knew we could do
that using logic so we changed it to a
robot sound effect and it sounded cool
it didn't sound like a couple of
numbnuts sing a Rosenberg you know you
know but then we thought we've got this
robot singing in the song what are we
gonna do in the music video we've got to
have a robot in in the music video so
the bacon this is this is just an
example of how it isn't totally ever
determined from the beginning the bacon
bot which is the focal point of the
entire music video and ultimately the
point they like the application point at
the end it was only created because we
didn't like the way we sounded in the
chorus and added a robot voice and then
needed a robot to sing it and then
decided well let's just build this in
Jason ended up building that that robot
in my backyard over a number of days
because like we got to have a robot how
do you build a robot well we can use a
trash can and we can get an old phone
and then we could put Nick Bishop in it
in it and the robot has to be able to
fry bacon so therefore let's make the
head a lot of a functioning George
Foreman great he ended up not be funk
funk tional yeah it wasn't plugged into
anything and now he's dead he fell off
the top of the refrigerator and the
whole his whole head busted but he's
still there I mean I think it could be
heated yeah if maybe he could be
salvaged but I mean those are kind of
the ways that we come up with ideas from
our brains from sponsors from fans but
there are sometimes and we don't have
the luxury of a lot of time
just to do this anymore but maybe we
never did but I know there were certain
points that we would just say you know
what today let's write a song with no
constraint so let's just sit down with a
guitar and a notepad and just open our
brains and just vomit out whatever comes
out hopefully it just won't be like more
poop humor and we found a demo that
rerecorded right so this is one we
recorded we were at down to the beach
this is a North Carolina number of years
ago this is before we moved to
California so this is probably four
years ago and we were sitting there just
what link said we want to write
something that has no constraints and it
was a song about a dream that we had and
this is let me let me tell you this is a
very early demo this is kind of catching
us in the middle of a writing session
and trying to kind of capture what we
had the song would be conversational and
so you would be telling me about a dream
that you had last night and I would be
responding to it right and then there
would be a second verse where I would
have a dream and you will respond to it
we never wrote the second verse about my
dream but we kind of ran with your dream
just because and tried to draw a
conclusion on the end of it and I think
I was like really far back from your
iPhone which was recording so it's hard
to hear me it's not a great recording
link sounds like he's across the room
because he was but I you know I actually
still like this song you'll get the idea
okay I was selling colored pencils all
roadside in a world of black and white
and then I noticed I was wearing nothing
but my floors and then a big panda bear
came out of nowhere holding the key he
said didn't the bear that came a woman
but she looked like Bruce Springsteen
and she lit up purple man burst in me
summon in the committee for the bee
urbanization of cities she was given a
presentation she invented a two-seater
scooter that was fueled by facial hair I
shaved my whole face and then I took my
trimmer can shave both my legs and what
she had oh my were you there
[Music]
and then she ate it all my
and then she went no no no
you should go oh that's what makes it a
- more like
[Music]
[Music]
and then she exploded my hair went
everywhere in the world we came color I
think it means of course it means
something go away your face your hair
especially if all minutes ago she was a
panda bear don't trust a panda - just
ate your body
naturally your underwear to end up
airless and alone
[Music]
don't ride a scooter that runs on facial
hair we had a lot of facial hair humor
in there we did and we can salvage that
song there's something in there is it's
kind of nuts but it could work it
reminds me of that song we wrote a long
time ago a tribute to friends with your
friends it just it was kind of a story
and it was based on nonsense yes well
there's a lot of nonsense there and I
think it's a good answer to this
question from Miranda Renee ran three
she says can you tell us some of the
ideas that you haven't followed through
with well there's one right there
Miranda I mean we've got a lot of these
there's a lot that we won't play for you
but things that we had an idea and we
kind of ran with it and then we got to a
point where we're like one of this this
probably doesn't need to go public it
would usually the ideas that we develop
do find their way onto the Internet
right but occasionally especially in the
past we would try a lot of different
things that might not make it like this
dream song I don't remember exactly why
we decided you know what we just open up
our brains why do we decide not to do
that did not default it's because we got
back from the beach and we had other
stuff to do and we never got back to it
right I mean that's how it happens a lot
of time okay I found another one that we
will never go back to well we're going
to it right now though this is what you
get when you listen to your biscuits and
we are no one's ever heard this thing
now when I played this for you earlier
did you remember that we had done this
vaguely this songs got at all people it
has it it has it's a it's like a it has
bathroom humor it has potty humor
literally it's all about the bathroom it
is about that awkward situation when
you're in a public restroom that's like
a one person at a time but somebody
knocks on the door and you have to
figure out what you're going to say
before they like try to like shimmy the
door open letting no one's in there but
the genres that we combined for this or
I was just messing around like I don't
know why you made the the voice that you
made so
so horrible it was just crazy we're like
let's just do the craziest thing let's
throw this drums on there you can sing
in a nasal voice I'm gonna try out all
these things in GarageBand I've never
used before as many years ago it's
called public place
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
that's crazy
I love the India I I really like where
that song oh man that is quite possibly
the stupidest thing we've ever done I'm
sort of liking it a third or fourth time
I've heard it today as we've prepared
for this but maybe we should make it
into a music video yeah so again things
have changed a lot the more things
change the more they stay the same
well the interesting thing is you know
we work in a different way today I mean
one of the things has changed about the
way we work is we have a team of people
we have things scheduled out more in
advance and so there's not just time
necessarily for us to sit around and
write that but back when that was
written it was just the two of us for
the fun we just come into the to the
office and we say all right well I got
an idea for this public place private
thing and then it's like alright well
I'm gonna do this weird drumbeat this
country thing that you've come up with
we would never let ourselves do that at
now but hopefully I'm hoping there can
be a time I do want to do this thing
where we like to rent a cabin mm-hmm and
go up there for an extended period of
time and write a whole album just a
whole album and it might end up singing
like this and you could do the proof
the Russian thing that'd be great what
will happen is onra yeah whether people
will listen to it is another story or
question okay listen I found one more
song and this is a complete demo that I
found and based on what the song is
written about I'm kind of deciphering
that it was written free maybe still
while we were engineers well but the
quality of the demo so good that I think
is later but you're certainly we're
certainly pulling on principles but on
the engineering they don't block my
YouTube so it had to be after 2005
that's true so it would this was but all
the humor was based on based on being in
the workplace yeah here's the angle the
song that no one has ever heard it's
called don't block my YouTube and it is
written from the perspective of someone
like an engineer who works in like a
cubicle job and he's just getting
started and his biggest fear is that the
boss will block YouTube at his place of
work which happens oh yeah they won't
let you look at YouTube cuz you'll waste
your time and not get your job done and
we would never write a song like this
today because it's too geared towards
the workplace and I you know that's not
yeah that's not where a lot of our fans
are at or care about that type of thing
so we're not going to write cubicle
humor but I did think it was interesting
that this is like a complete almost it
sounded almost produced demo I only
start singing at the end I remember you
wrote most of song and I wrote this
thing at the end and started singing it
yeah so there's like two and a half
minutes and uh then there's light link
comes in it's like okay it's a surprise
I like it
well we just spoil the surprise ladies
and gentlemen the world premiere of
don't block my YouTube
the first thing you'll notice is that
you're beginning to gain some weight
face it dude
because you don't meet your target heart
rate on your commute before you know it
you'll be parting your hair and tucking
in your business casual shirt because
your foe hunk and Miller Genuine Draft
t-shirt just don't work at work at first
you will be averse to do a number two in
the restroom you think what if my boss
comes in he would know me by my shoes
but just give it two months you be
relishing your precious time in the John
because it's the only time you can have
conversations with anyone from circuit
level management you go crazy trap there
in that queue if your balls ever makes
that dreadful decision to put a backup
on you two
there will be a certain girl at work you
would have never noticed back in school
but here in the office setting
she seems enter pinstripe and suit
you're thinking about asking her out but
let me set your perspective right what
you think is a 10 on Monday you go crazy
cooped up in a queue back and your boss
if that sucker decides to put a plaque
up on YouTube and don't forget those me
tease me tease once when all these
thinking mean he's leading after you
leading your own freakin meeting about
meetings me meetings just to make more
meetings let's call the meeting so we
can minimize
[Music]
Oh
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
it took you a while to come in there but
you really came in strong and you really
finished strong I like that song man I
just like a Nickelback record ripoff or
something well I felt very weird al'
very nasally you're very high singing
there will be a certain girl at work you
would have never noticed back at school
that's harsh that hold it hold logic
there that I came up with yeah we would
never say that publicly now that's it's
kind of sexist a little bit but but but
still a completely formed song that no
one's ever heard until right now on this
ear biscuit because you decided to stick
around and hang out with us for this
amount of time so we're truly grateful
I think the hopefully one of the things
that has been demonstrated here is that
if you think that some of our music is
actually good which hopefully you do you
see that the only way that that even has
a chance of happening is a whole lot of
bad to happen yeah you know you you have
to churn out so much stuff creatively in
order to get to the things that you
actually want to share with people but
you just that you've got to get that
engine going you've got to get the
machine working so something will come
out of it so then you can say okay I got
this out of the way so I could get to
the next thing and maybe the next thing
or the thing after that'll be the thing
that I actually want to share but I
don't know I spit cinnamon listening to
this stuff and kind of being reminded of
you know we've been doing this a long
time it doesn't think I'm struck with
some of the some of these these songs
are from I mean were the first ones from
the year 2000 yeah that's about 14 years
ago it's kind of depressing actually I
mean the thing that struck me having
going back through this is the amount of
fun that we had developing this
I don't know if I would call it a skill
but developing this practice and this of
collaboratively writing a song you know
I've seen footage of comedy writing
duo's who can just sit down and they can
write a script and we've we do very
little of that but we do very much of
that when it comes to a song it's it's
funny how a song kind of brings out the
best and both of us in terms of being
able to contribute to something and
create something because our brains do
work differently and we we care about
the same things but then we're also have
the capacity to care about different
things at the same time and make a it's
but it mostly I'm saying it's fun to
write a song I mean the best part about
high school was being in a band
writing crappy music and then you know
whenever we would sit down in college
and ever since then when you sit down we
have to divide things up a lot but
there's there's a lot of fun and there's
like a magical thing that happens when
you can sit down and kind of kind of
craft a song that comes together and
it's this cohesive thing that you wanna
you can listen to a whole bunch well
there's just something about this is why
I really hope and I think this will be
the case that music will continue to be
a cornerstone of what we create mm-hmm
there have been times where we've gotten
a little bit slack with the amount of
songs that we're putting out right yeah
we've gone for a long period of time
where we're not putting out songs not
writing new music and putting out music
videos but there's just something when
you go back and listening to listen to
things like this it's just totally
different experience to go back and
listen to an old song to hear the
iterative process of those five
different stages of a song as it was
being written it's something that
doesn't happen when you go back and
watch a video you know because that's
not how you know that's not how you make
videos you don't make the video five
times you hopefully and you talk about
it and plan it and script it and then
you go shoot it and then you edit it and
maybe there's a couple of different
edits but there's just something about
music just from a from a creative
standpoint that
is different is better and talking about
these listening to this listen to these
old songs that we haven't listened to
some we're hearing for the first time as
we playing for each other
yeah makes me want to write more yeah I
feel energized let's go write a song
what are we gonna are we going to give
them the scoop on something that where
the next song we're gonna write like I
can tell you the voice I'm gonna be sing
it in I hope that's okay with you let us
know hashtag ear biscuits well not what
you think of that I know what you think
of that what you thought of this episode
again it's you know there's an
experimental nature to the two of us
having a conversation guestlist we're
certainly not going to give up our
guests and you can count on that next
week but give us some hashtag ear
biscuits feedback I will say one thing
though as your is your putting like
putting together your tweets
hashtag ear biscuits or leaving your
comment a review and rating on iTunes
which again as we've established helps a
whole lot please do that a great way to
support the show I don't think I want to
do much more unintentionally country
music hmm I think that's one of the
things that I hear in a lot of what we
what we've done is that we would write a
country song
not realizing as it was a country song
just because we come from such a country
background yes so much of what we listen
to is just net for the country and when
we start singing the chords that we'll
play and the melodies that we will sing
you naturally fall into that country
thing we've gotten to this place where
we have to be like no no guys this is a
rock song or this is a pop song or this
is a rap song it cannot be a country
song now because country's bad but
because when you write a song that you
want to be a pop song and then somebody
listens to it no it's not a country it
doesn't work it ruins the comedy because
the clarity of the comedic angle that
we're trying to get across is ruined so
I don't think I'm gonna be singing like
this haven't you knew some weird
percussion unless we decide to just do a
no this is a legitimate country song
which I do
have an idea for a country song about
grilled cheese remember that one I think
that's that's half written already but
you know maybe maybe we shouldn't go
there I can I need to dig up that demo
that's the good one okay thanks for
hanging out with us like I said you can
count on us to speak into your ears via
a biscuit next week and every Friday
thanks for leaving that iTunes review
and for supporting our musical endeavors
yes a great way to do that is by
listening to it what else what else do
you want to say rap nothing
me neither
[Music]
[Music]